Eh, still.
>> U.S. BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWEMD AND WE HAVEN’T
RECEIVED AN ADEQUATE RESPONSE
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
AND TODAY I’M ANNOUNCING WE’RE
DEPLOYING THE NATIONAL GUARD ON
OUR OWN.
THIS ADMINISTRATION ISN’T GOING
TO DO ANYTHING, WE WILL.
>> Harris: ARIZONA GOVERNOR
DOUG DUCEY TAKING MATTERS INTO
HIS OWN HANDS AND DEPLOYING 250
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO THE
BORDER.
HIS STATE IS STRUGGLING TO
PROCESS A RECORD NUMBER OF
INFLUX OF MIGRANTS AND NEARLY
EVERY DAY WE SEE NEW IMAGES
WHICH ILLUSTRATE HOW SERIOUS
THE CRISIS IS.
BORDER OFFICIALS EARLIER THIS
MONTH STOPPED A COMMERCIAL
TRAILER PACKED WITH NEARLY 150
MIGRANTS TRYING TO CROSS
ILLEGALLY INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
NONE OF THEM WAS WEARING A MASK
WHEN THEY WERE APPREHENDED.
WE HAVE TO TEST THESE PEOPLE
AND TREAT THESE PEOPLE.
A LOOT THAT GOES INTO THIS.
CHIP ROY OF TEXAS JOINS ME NOW
AND HE IS PUSHING HARD FOR A
VOTE ON LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
REINSTATE ENFORCEMENT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S COVID-19
PROTOCOLS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AS MIGRANTS OVERCROWD
FACILITIES.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM,
CONGRESSMAN.
FIRST OF ALL TELL ME ABOUT THIS
EFFORT AND WHY IT IS SO DIRE.
>> GLAD TO BE ON THE SHOW.
LET ME TAKE A FEW SECONDS TO
BRING UP THE ABSURD TEE OF WHAT
MAXINE WATERS DID AND MAKING
THE POINT SHE MAY HAVE
JEOPARDIZED THE CASE CAUSING A
JUDGE TO QUESTION WHETHER IT
WOULD GO DOWN ON APPEAL BECAUSE
OF WHAT SHE SAID.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THAT
UP.
IT IS A TRAVESTY.
WHAT ELSE IS A TRAVESTY IS
WHAT’S HAPPENING AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
CARTELS HAVE OPERATIONAL
CONTROL OF OUR BOARD.
ANYBODY FOLLOWING IT KNOWS THAT.
THE STATE ACROSS THE BORDER
FROM TEXAS IS RUN BY A CARTEL
AND THE CARTEL.
THEY ARE USING HUMAN BEINGS AS
SHIELDS FOR PROFIT.
THEY ARE MOVING PEOPLE INTO
TEXAS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES, SAN
ANTONIO WHICH I REPRESENT.
WE’VE STOPPED VEHICLES WITH
HUMAN BEINGS BEING SENT TO
STASH HOUSES IN HOUSTON TO BE
USED FOR PROFIT AND TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SEX TRAFFICKING.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY, A
SUBURBAN TOWN OF SAN ANTONIO.
NINE INDIVIDUALS HEADED TO
STASH HOUSE.
ONE BOY PAID $4,000 TO THE
CARTEL TO BE SENT TO GO PICK
GRAPES IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY DIDN’T TELL HIM YOU ARE
GOING TO A STASH HOUSE.
THE MOST POWERFUL NATION IN THE
WORLD WE’RE ALLOWING IT TO
OCCUR.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS BEEN ON THE
JOB FOR A MONTH.
LITERALLY SHE HAS DONE NOTHING.
SHE HAS NOT GONE TO THE BORDER.
SHE HAS DONE NOTHING TO ADDRESS
THIS.
YESTERDAY I FILED A DISCHARGE
PETITION OF MY FRIEND’S BILL TO
REQUIRE TITLE 42, THE CDC’S
REQUIREMENT AND GUIDELINES WE
PROTECT AGAINST THE INFLUX OF
PANDEMICS INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
THAT WE RESUME ENFORCING THAT
WHICH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS REFUSED TO DO.
NOW WE’LL FORCE A VOTE ON THE
FLOOR OF THE HOUSE.
IF WE CAN GET UP TO SIX
DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES TO AGREE WE
SHOULD SECURE OUR BORDER AND
FIGHT AGAINST THE SPREAD OF THE
PANDEMIC.
>> Harris: AND HAVE YOU BEEN
TALKING WITH DEMOCRATS TO SEE
IF YOU’LL GET THAT KIND OF
SUPPORT?
>> WELL FIRST JOB IS TO GET IT
DOWN ON THE FLOOR.
WE GOT SIGNATURES GROWING.
WHEN ALL REPUBLICANS SIGN IT
WE’LL WORK WITH OUR DEMOCRATS
COLLEAGUES.
I HAVE GREAT FRIENDS LIKE HENRY
CUELLAR ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND UNDERSTANDS HOW BAD IT IS.
I HOPE HENLEY AND SOME OTHERS
WILL JOIN US IN THE EFFORT.
THIS IS A SIMPLE QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK WE OUGHT TO EMPLOY
ALL TOOLS THAT OUR DISPOSAL TO
STOP THE FLOW COMING ACROSS OUR
BORDER AND PROTECT AMERICANS
AGAINST THE DANGEROUS PANDEMIC
WHEN WE’RE STILL HAVING
LOCKDOWNS AND STILL HAVING
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE AND MASK
GUIDELINES AND PROTOCOLS HERE?
WHY AREN’T WE DOING WHAT WE ARE
DOING TO SECURE THE BORDER?
>> Harris: I THINK IT’S AN
OBVIOUS QUESTION.
I HAVEN’T HEARD IT ASKED.
WHY WOULD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WIPE AROUND
TITLE 42 AND PROTECTIONS
REGARDING COVID?
IS THERE SOME SORT OF KNOWLEDGE
THE PANDEMIC HAS ENDED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT WE DON’T KNOW
ABOUT?
>> I WISH THEY WOULD TELL US TO
GET ALL THE SMALL BUSINESSES
STRUGGLING AND ALL OF THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON OUR
ECONOMY, SCHOOLS STILL SHUT
DOWN.
I HOPE THEY TELL US AND WISH
THEY WOULD STOP PUTTING DR.
FAUCI OUT THERE TO CONTINUE TO
CONFUSE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT IS HAPPENING AT OUR BORDER
THEY’RE DOING IT FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
SIMPLE.
ALLOWING CARTELS TO GET
EMPOWERED.
MEXICO TO BECOME MORE
DANGEROUS, TEXAS AND OTHER
STATES LIKE ARIZONA TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE CRISIS OF DANGER
ON RANCHS IN OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, SCHOOLS LIKE I SAID.
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
THAT WAS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
DRIVING THE CAR BEING PAID BY
THE CARTELS.
IT EXISTS IN YOUR COMMUNITIES,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
THE CARTELS ARE OPERATING IN
YOUR SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES NOT
JUST THE TEXT A AS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DON’T
CARE AND IGNORING WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER WITH
RESPECT TO COVID.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE COVID
INFECTED CHILDREN IN THE
FACILITY.
HOW DO I KNOW THAT?
I WENT THERE.
YOU KNOW WHO HASN’T GONE THERE?
KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY ONLY WANT TO USE IT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES RATHER THAN
DOING THEIR JOB TO SECURE THE
BORDER.
BORDER PATROL, YOU TALK TO THE
BORDER PATROL UNION REGULARLY.
OUR GREAT GUYS DOWN THERE.
THEY WILL TELL YOU TITLE 42 IS
THE TOOL THEY’VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO STOP THE FLOW AT THE BORDER
AND BE ABLE TO HOLD THE LINE.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN RID
OF IT FOR KIDS AND FAMILIES BUT
NOW THEY’RE RUMBLING GETTING
RID OF IT FOR EVERYBODY.
IF THEY DO THAT THE BUM RUSH AT
OUR BORDER WILL MAKE THE
171,000 IN MARCH SEEM LIKE A
TRIVIAL NUMBER.
>> Harris: I MEAN SOME OF IT
FALLS ON THE HANDS, TOO, OF THE
DOCTORS AND NURSES THAT WILL
HAVE TO HELP CARE FOR PEOPLE IN
AND WHEN THEY ARE FOUND
POSITIVE.
I’VE BEEN REPORTING HUNDREDS OF
POSITIVES THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
THAT TESTING AT THE BORDER SO
IT BECOMES A POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS SITUATION THAT WE
BEAR THE BRUNT OF.
WE’RE TRYING TO SAVE LIVES IN
ADDITION TO TRYING TO SAVE
LIVES.
IT IS A LAYERING EFFECT OF THEM
COMING ACROSS AND COMING ACROSS
SICK POTENTIALLY.
>> CAN I ADD IT IS ALSO PART OF
THE DETERRENT?
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF EL
SALVADOR GOING ON TUCKER A FEW
WEEKS BACK AND SAYING YOU ARE
DRAWING PEOPLE OUT OF MY
COUNTRY AND DECIMATING MY
COUNTRY.
HOW ABOUT THE 7-YEAR-OLD GIRL I
MET AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT HER BEFORE
WHO WAS ALL ALONE, COMING UP
THROUGH MEXICO.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRAT
ADMINISTRATION IS ENCOURAGING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ENCOURAGING MORE FLOW INSTEAD
OF USING THE TOOLS WE HAVE AT
OUR DISPOSAL TO STOP THE FLOW
AT THE BORDER.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
PROTECTING AMERICANS,
PROTECTING IMMIGRANTS, AND NOT
EMPOWERING CARTELS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DOESN’T DO THAT.
ASK YOUR CONGRESSMAN GO GET ON
THIS DISCHARGE PETITION TO
FORCE A VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
DEMOCRATS WON’T DO IT ON THEIR
OWN.
>> Harris: WE’LL BRING YOU
BACK, CONGRESSMAN CHIP ROY, TO
GET A REPORT AND UPDATE ON ALL
OF THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING